Meine Damen und Herren, der Präsident
der Vereinigten Staaten, Donald Trump, unser
beispielloses Treffen, das erste zwischen
einem amerikanischen Präsidenten und einem Führer
Nordkoreas, beweist, dass echte Veränderungen
tatsächlich möglich sind. Wir sind bereit,
eine neue Geschichte zu beginnen, und wir sind bereit, eine zu schreiben
neues Kapitel zwischen der Vergangenheit unserer Nation
muss nicht die Zukunft definieren
Der Konflikt von gestern muss nicht
der Krieg von morgen sein und wie die Geschichte immer wieder bewiesen hat,
können Gegner
tatsächlich Freunde werden, jeder kann
Krieg führen, aber nur die Mutigsten können
Frieden schließen  Ein sehr großartiger Tag, es ist ein
sehr großartiger Moment in der Geschichte der
Welt, und Vorsitzender Kim, er ist auf dem Weg
zurück nach Nordkorea, und ich weiß genau
, sobald er ankommt, wird
er einen Prozess beginnen, der viele Menschen bewegen wird
sehr glücklich und sehr sicher, also ist
es eine Ehre, heute mit allen zusammen zu sein,
die Medien, es ist eine große Ansammlung von Medien,
ich werde sagen, dass ich mich sehr unwohl fühle
[Applaus]